I remember sitting there during the
ceremony thinking this is so crazy that
I am sitting in this chair next to these
guys who I admire so much let alone in
that room with all those other people
and I purposely didn't plan anything to
say cuz I thought don't waste your time
planning something to say because you're
not going to win and you're just going
to sit there and be worried about what
you're going to say what you're going to
say and make sure you get it right and I
just didn't want to do that I just
wanted to enjoy the night if you win
great you'll think of something to say
between the time you stand up and the
time you get to the stage you'll have to
it'll force you to think of something
and I remember watching them they were
up in the center of the stage and it was
Jennifer Lopez here are the nominees for
best original score and she's reading
off the nominees and all of that and
then they say that I won and the winner
is Michael Gino for up and I'm like okay
that's weird so I stand up and I'm kind
of like okay what do I do now Pete
doctor comes over and hugs me and I see
different people that I know and as I'm
going up I'm heading towards where I had
last seen the people standing in the
center of the stage what I didn't know
was they moved over to which I think is
stage right so I'm walking up there and
if you look at the video I look like I'm
lost I don't know what I'm doing and
then suddenly I'm like oh there you are
and it was just one of those weird outof
body experiences and then when I got up
there all I could think about was like
wow really the only reason I'm here is
because of my parents when I said I
wanted to make movies they never ever
once said that being creative was a
waste of time and it's truly not and I
think that if we had more people being
creative in this world it'd be a far
better place I know there are kids out
there that don't have that support
system so if you're out there and you're
listening listen to me if you want to be
creative get out there and do it it's
not a waste of time do it okay thank you
thank
you